[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 24 mai voici les
titres la venue de marion maréchal dans
les yvelines la vice-présidente de
reconquête était en meeting à versailles
là où eric zemmour avait totalisé 18 %
des suffrages au premier tour de la
présidentielle un déplacement de soutien
au candidat du parti à moins de deux
semaines des élections législatives
la clé de saint-pierre elancourt va
entamer sa mue le quartier fera l'objet
d'une grande rénovation paysagère en vue
des jo de paris 2024 dont la ville
accueillera les épreuves de vtt le
projet a été présenté aux habitants
samedi lors d'une rencontre festive et
puis ce sera assurément l'un des
événements de l'été dans les yvelines du
10 juin au 3 juillet le spectacle secret
défense vous replongera dans le sommet
d'état entre le président de gaulle et
eisenhower au château de rambouillet
nous avons pu assister à la dernière
grande répétition
mais avant de commencer un grand
colloque sur la cyber sécurité il se
déroule ce mardi soir au théâtre
montansier de versailles l'événement a
débuté à 16h30 et va se poursuivre
jusqu'à 22 heures c'est organisé par le
mouvement européen des yvelines sur
place on retrouve nicolas landry et nous
sommes au théâtre montansier de
versailles avec christian franck le
président du mouvement européen des
yvelines bonsoir bonsoir alors vous on
est ici parce que ce soir ici on va
parler cybersécurité il ya des ateliers
à des colloques quels sont les enjeux
vous allez aborder ce soir alors ce sont
les enjeux de la cybersécurité comme son
nom l'indiqué au niveau france et aussi
surtout au niveau européen puisque bien
sûr la france et d'un briquet dans
l'union européenne et la cybersécurité
n'a pas de frontières donc effectivement
c'est un colloque qui va se dérouler en
deux parties une partie de 17 heures à
19 heures avec quatre ateliers
thématiques et une partie proprement
conférence à partir de 20 heures ici
dans la salle du théâtre et donc les
ateliers vont tourner autour de la
formation ils vont tourner autour de la
protection des données
des particuliers mais aussi des
entreprises et des collectivités locales
c'est très important et puis ils vont
tourner également autour de la défense
avec la cyber défense qui sera
d'ailleurs animé par un général de
gendarmerie et puis il y aura également
un atelier qui proposera des solutions
les solutions techniques comment éviter
les attaques les cyber attaques on l'a
vu pendant la crise sanitaire il ya déjà
eu de nombreuses attaques faites contre
les services publics contre les hôpitaux
là on le voit avec la guerre en ukraine
l'enjeu cybersécurité est vraiment au
coeur de la société aujourd'hui la
cybersécurité est au coeur de la société
parce que maintenant
les cyberattaques ce set une arme c'est
une arme d'attac comme son nom l'indiqué
et il faut se défendre donc ça fait
partie aussi des enjeux de défense
nationale et de défense des entreprises
des collectivités locales comme on l'a
dit parce que maintenant l'informatique
et le coeur même de nos sociétés comment
est né ce projet d'organiser cette
soirée au mouvement européen des
yvelines parce que nous sommes dans la
présidence française de l'union
européenne actuellement jusqu'au mois de
juin et que le président macron en tant
que président de l'union européenne du
conseil de l'union européenne a ciblé
cette thématique au coeur des priorités
européennes c'est pourquoi nous en tant
que moment européen nous avons repris
cette thématique pour le colloque est
bien merci christian franck je rappelle
que vous êtes le président du mouvement
européen des yvelines et on va tout de
suite rejoindre benoît de saint sernin
qui est directeur de l'école européenne
de cybersécurité de versailles pour
parler justement de l'atelier organisé
concernant la formation en cybersécurité
on se retrouve à l'école européenne de
cybersécurité de versailles non pas avec
le président mais le directeur de cet
établissement grégoire chataignon
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur alors ici dans
quelques minutes il va y avoir un
atelier en quoi consiste cet atelier de
ce soir dans le cadre de du colloque de
cybersécurité organisée par le mouvement
européen des yvelines vient le moment au
point des yvelines souhaité s'intéresser
à la formation voilà du coup le premier
atelier dans un ordre quelque part qui
logique s'intéresse justement aux enjeux
de formation donc seront présents d'une
part le lit le lycée militaire de saint
cyr qui a un bts en cybersécurité et
puis nous mêmes donc l'école européenne
de si leur sécurité
durant laquelle bon on pourra débattre
justement deux de ces enjeux de
formation et en particulier de la
formation du niveau technicien puisque
les deux formations à la fois le lycée
militaire de saint cyr et nous mêmes le
cs formant des techniciens en
cybersécurité comment on peut décrire
aujourd'hui la formation en
cybersécurité en france et notamment
dans les yvelines
alors
mallet métier la cybersécurité en fait
il ya plusieurs niveaux il ya les
niveaux ingénieurs dont on entend
beaucoup parler mais de toutes les
tâches ne sont ne nécessite pas pour
être réalisés forcément un diplôme et un
niveau d'ingénieur et entre autres et
aussi donc des formations qui se
développe pour le niveau technicien donc
les gens qui vont faire gagner des
dizaines d'heures chaque semaine aux
ingénieurs informatiques et qui vont
leur permettre de se concentrer eux sur
leur lors de leur plus value qui leur
est propre donc au niveau d'ingénieur et
donc nous les buts c'est de former des
techniciens donc est vraiment l'ouvrier
de la cyber qui va faire gagner ces
dizaines d'heures chaque semaine qui va
être heureux de travailler à ce niveau
là puisqu'il y aurait été formé pour il
sera dans sa zone de confort cc des
formations qui sont post bac où il faut
faire des années d'études supérieures
avant de rejoindre ce type de formation
alors pour le niveau technicien ce sont
des formations post bac
donc nous par exemple ce que nous
faisons c'est que nous prenons des
débutants en informatique le programme
est fait pour nous prenons des grands
des loyers des débutants en informatique
et en deux ans nous allons délivrer un
titre d'opérateur en cybersécurité et
donc avant d'en faire un professionnel
de la cybersécurité on va faire de cette
personne
on va faire passer par des métiers
intermédiaires par exemple le métier de
technicien systèmes et réseaux bon et
bien d'autres aussi voilà un dernier mot
en quoi aujourd'hui la formation elle
est essentielle pour pour la
cybersécurité on entend beaucoup parler
d'eux des besoins de recrutement il ya
énormément de demandes et en face il ya
pas beaucoup
finalement d'offres c'est ça c'est pour
ça que la formation est essentielle
aujourd'hui en mairie tout à fait alors
leur balise enjeux de la cybersécurité
aujourd'hui bon je pense commence à être
connu du grand public
c'est vrai pour le milieu industriel
c'est vrai pour le milieu économique et
au sens général du terme et à certains
événements qui n'ont fait que la
remettre en exergue que ça scola
pandémie que ce soient les événements
internationaux en ukraine et autres
alors et des chiffres que j'ai en tête
qu'il est par exemple de 2019 faisait
état d'un besoin de recrutement de 40
mille personnes dans ce secteur en
france dans les quatre années à venir
voilà ces chiffres n'ont fait
qu'augmenter et donc nous à notre petite
place eh bien nous vous apportons notre
pierre à l'édifice donc en forme ans ces
fameuses opérateurs en cybersécurité et
ses techniciens systèmes et réseaux
merci beaucoup mais bien écouter merci
de
de votre interview puis merci mme aux
téléspectateurs de
leur attention pour ce sujet
d'importance sujet d'importance et sujet
qui est au coeur ce soir des discussions
au théâtre montansier à versailles
toujours à versailles marion maréchal
était de passage pour soutenir les
candidats reconquête dans les yvelines
aux élections législatives le scrutin se
déroule les 12 et 19 juin 300 personnes
ont fait le déplacement pour ce meeting
dans une ville où eric zemmour a
totalisé 18 % des voix lors du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
mathilde franco en passant du burqini à
la pma et au mariage pour tous ou encore
en faisant le bilan des manuels
maquereau en dressant la menace de
jean-luc mélenchon les sujets et les
critiques n'ont pas manqué lundi 23 mai
lors de la venue de marion maréchal à
versailles la vice-présidente de
reconquête est venu soutenir les
candidats dans les yvelines aux
législatives elle contient pas que les
grands du bug qui peuvent
potentiellement transformer le seuil
d'éviter se trouve que par ailleurs
c'est vrai que les yvelines et en
particulier ces deux circonscriptions
sur les circonscriptions sur lesquels
nous avons un potentiel électoral
non négligeable et pour un peu que les
électeurs de reconquête
du premier tour de ces élections
présidentielles se mobilisent en masse
bien nous pourrions créer la surprise à
versailles eric zemmour a réalisé une
véritable percée au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec 18 48%
des voix c'est donc dans une salle
comble de 300 personnes environ que
marion maréchal était attendu je suis
fan déjà de marion maréchal et puis tant
venez à versailles ça me tenait à coeur
de soutenir les candidats aux
législatives
ça fait super plaisir d'une foule devant
une femme s'y engager
si convaincu et qui a un vrai projet
pour la france nous elle nous a
complètement redonner espoir et
envie de croire en la politique ce qu'on
avait perdu à la suite des élections je
crois que l'avenir de la france est tout
tracé avec marion les 12 candidats
reconquête des yvelines étaient
également présents pour accueillir leur
vice présidente aujourd'hui reconquête
c'est le vrai discours de droite qui n'a
pas oublié une partie des convictions de
la droite à savoir la partie des
libertés la liberté d'entreprendre le
courage de revendiquer nos racines
judéo-chrétiennes l'ensemble des
candidats sont ensuite montés sur scène
pour entamer la marseillaise puis marion
maréchal est allé à la rencontre des
participants et pendant toute la
campagne des élections législatives tv
60,18 vous aide à y voir plus clair sur
ce scrutin des 12 et 19 juin focus
aujourd'hui sur la troisième
circonscription des yvelines avec justin
brasil bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
une troisième circonscription qui
regroupe 12 communes exactement alors
elle est située à l'est du département
est la troisième circonscription des
yvelines s'étend donc du généreux
concours jusqu'à feucherolles je vais
pas vous citer toutes les communes
puisque comme vous l'avez dit à grégory
lui en a 12 mai on retrouve par exemple
bougival à la celle saint cloud a les
clés sous bois saint nom la bretèche ou
encore villepreux elle regroupe environ
115 mille habitants des villes largement
remporté par emmanuel macron à
l'élection présidentielle 2022 il
obtient plus de 40% des votes au premier
tour et plus de 70% dans presque toutes
ces villes au deuxième tour et si on
regarde l'historique sur ce territoire
on est plutôt en créer centre-droit oui
depuis un bon moment parce que si on
repart en 2002 c'est anne marie idrac
qui l'emportent la représentante de
l'union pour la démocratie française
donc partis de droite et du centre en
2007 elle c'est christian blanc qui est
élu dès le premier tour lui pour l'ump
est toujours pour l'ump henri guaino en
2012 est élu et puis en 2010 est donc
c'est béatrice piron chefs d'entreprise
et nouvelle venue dans le monde
politique qui remporte la 6e la
circonscription pour la république en
marche cette fois ci elle est élu au
second tour avec 58 93 % des votes elle
faisait face à l'époque à philippe
brillault pour les républicains qui
était alors maire du chesnay et cette
année pour cette nouvelle élection
béatrice pire on brigue un nouveau
mandat ah oui la députée sortante a
déposé sa candidature et se représente
aux élections législatives pour la même
circonscription
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
elle se présente cette fois ci pour la
bannière ensemble et donc qui regroupe
six partis politiques dont la république
en marche devenu renaissance le modem et
horizons et c'est officiel nous avons
reçu la liste définitive aujourd'hui lui
aurait dit candidat dans cette
circonscription sort au total dix
candidats exactement liste officielle
parmi les autres candidats on retrouve
bertrand coquard adjoint au maire des
clayes-sous-bois candidats de la droite
et du centre ils représentent les
républicains et lui dit appeler après
rappelons le un faible score obtenu à la
présidentielle pour le parti et même au
niveau national et même au sein du
département il est soutenu par sébastien
guérin ancien maire-adjoint de philippe
brillault enchaîné rocancourt après
avoir annoncé sa candidature celui ci
s'est retirée pour appeler à se
rassembler donc à derrière bertrand
coquard louise brody elle sera là
représentants de la coalition ne baisse
donc nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale elle fait partie des huit
candidats de la france insoumise investi
par la coalition à savoir pardon au
premier tour de la présidentielle
jean-luc mélenchon avait obtenu environ
20% des votes dans trois communes donc
de cette circonscription est les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux et la celle
saint cloud et puis pour le reste des
candidats pierre yves painchaud
conseiller municipal de mézières sur
seine fait campagne pour le
rassemblement national jean-françois
accueillir présentera le nouveau parti
donc reconquête olivier augustin ouvrier
dans l'automobile se présente pour la
lutte ouvrière et puis lionel deschamps
pour le parti animalistes merci justin
on rappelle les dates des élections
législatives les 12 et 19 juin prochain
et dans l'actualité également une
aventure incroyable qui aurait pu coûter
la vie de fille brio vous parliez de
philippe brillault justement justin est
aussi à son équipage c'est une prise
d'otages à laquelle il a échappé grâce à
son sang froid et son courage philippe
brillault est bien connue des yvelinois
il a été le maire du chesnay de chaîner
rocancourt pendant plus de trente ans et
des puits qui n'exerce plus cette
fonction il se consacre notamment à
l'une de ses passions qui est la voile
c'est ainsi qu'à la demande du
navigateur philippe poupon il a racheté
le bateau mythique et de florence
arthaud le pierre premier qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui le la côte à florence
arthaud avait remporté la route du rhum
sur ce trimaran et lors de la prochaine
édition philippe poupon en train de
réaliser le même exploit mais le lakota
se trouvaient dans les philippines il
fallait donc le ramener sur les côtes
françaises c'est l'expédition à laquelle
s'est consacré philippe brillault depuis
le mois de février il y avait plusieurs
routes possibles celle qui a été choisie
par td philippines pour le sri lanka du
sri lanka à djibouti et de djibouti au
canal de suez et c'est ce passage vers
les côtes yéménites qui étaient très
dangereux c'est un endroit où les
attaques de pirates sont très fréquentes
et c'est d'ailleurs en cette raison de
ce danger en raison de ce danger que
philippe brillault avait pris une arme à
son bord à bord de son bateau la suite
c'est l'attaqué des pirates que raconte
la femme de philippe brillault and père
brio témoignages recueillis par patrice
carmouze
phillips et son côté très très très
médecins urgentistes en fait il dit
toujours
dans n'importe quelle situation
dédramatiser et faire face et donc il
avait pris malgré tout alors que c'est
un pacifiste mais il avait pris malgré
tout il est quand même pas voire naïf et
donc il avait pris un pistolet
effectivement et qu'il est qui qui lui a
servi ils ont dû être repérés
probablement parce que c'est très
délicat en fait là la nav à ce niveau là
ils ont dû approcher un peu trop près
les côtes la côte yéménite
ils ont pu être repérés donc et ce
bateau évidemment mythique
bon c'est vrai que c'est un bateau qui
n'était pas passée inaperçue à djibouti
et donc ils ont vu tout d'un coup en
fait des bateaux arrivés à fond
sur eux qui visiblement on n'avait pas
des intentions très pacifiste et donc
comme il avait déjà eu un coup de
semonce repoussé quinze jours trois
semaines avant en fait philippe a
immédiatement pris son arme
mais les tirs les tirs étaient fournis
en fait pas assez et armés de
kalachnikov et de lance au fusil
d'assaut kalachnikov 13 les rennais
évidemment alors c'est ce qui se passe
sous l'eau avec ces pirates c'est que
ils prennent des bateaux ils prennent
les équipages en otage et demandent des
rançons courant c'est sa cité c'était
clairement l'objectif
d'enlever l'équipage et de détourner le
bateau pour une rançon philippe
brillault ils essaiment sur le pont il
as il a son arme et il a cette présence
d'esprit assez incroyable et ce courage
assez incroyable de tenir les pirates
avec son pistolet tout à fait oui en
fait donc un des skippers est parti en
cabine pour prévenir les secours
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs aussi que j'ai
été mise au courant
et puis l'autre skipper bon été et est
mort de trouille un don qu'il était
aplati
pour pour ne pas recevoir les balles et
c'est vrai que philippe
a vraiment pris son pistolet avec
beaucoup d'autorité pour les tenir en
joue
appelé à appeler les secours alors à
fait compensateur chose apple qui fait
non je crois voilà il fait un faux appel
leur foi regarder glee kopter qui va
arriver quoi ça voilà que les secours
allaient arriver qu'un hélicoptère aléas
des forces spéciales allait arriver et
en plus ce qui est incroyable c'est que
la gopro était pas loin et qu'il a eue
qui la présence d'esprit de films et de
les filmer ce qui leur a beaucoup déplu
et du coup devant tant de de
détermination en fait ils ont ils ont eu
un moment de ils ont été déconcertés en
fait par l'attitude de philippe qui est
pas une attitude
habituelle des
skippers sur les bateaux et donc
ils ont été et philippe a profité de ce
moment de de déstabilisation pour dire à
son coéquipier tut tut
tut mais les voilà font qu'on reprenne
de la vitesse et c'est là que le
flotteurs du trimaran
s'élevait donc après qu'un gars soient
montés sur le filet philippe pas réussi
à faire redescendre deux ans joue sur
son bateau et le chef a dit repli il ya
eu des tirs
d'ailleurs il ya des impacts évidemment
de balint le mât est très très abîmée
etc il ya eu des impacts
pour essayer en fait il voulait essayer
de couper leur vitesse
de 2 mètres d'affaler la grand voile en
fait est de faire en sorte de réduire la
vitesse et il n'y ont pas réussi ils ont
réussi à atteindre 8 noeuds puis 9 puis
10 puis 12
et donc du coup ils ont réussi à les
semer aucun des trois n'a été de laisser
enfin c'est incroyable
mon quartier demain c'est le nom de cet
événement proposé paraît long cours le
week end dernier la ville a profité de
ce moment festif pour présenter un
projet d'envergure la rénovation
paysagère du quartier de la clé de saint
pierre les travaux vont durer deux ans
explications
du changement pour ses 30 ans la clé de
saint pierre va entrer en chantier une
grande rénovation paysagère pour
revégétaliser le quartier élan courtois
de 6000 habitants l'objectif réinvestir
près de 20% de la surface public du
quartier d'arriver à améliorer la vérité
alisation et ainsi de permettre au
quartier non seulement de respirer mais
de fait de plus en plus frais pourquoi
parce qu'en fait tout ce qui est mettons
va réchauffer le coeur des villes pour
ce faire deux ans de travaux sont
nécessaires les opérations vont se
concentrer principalement autour de la
place de paris du collège de la clé
saint-pierre et de l'école jean-monnet
plantation de plus d'une centaine
d'arbres nouvel espace de brumisation
solutions de stationnement et
sécurisation sont prévus dans le projet
la passe de paris un moment très fort
avec she derrière la rue d'athènes et la
rue du luxembourg qui voit tam il agit
aussi pour nos commerces on va
structurer
des terrasses pour que nous commerçons
puisse exercer l'été de manière agréable
on va vers dire la place regardez notre
fontaine puisque l'eau est un élément
essentiel après on va avoir tout
l'aménagement devant le collège et à
côté de l'école pour être plus de
stationnement nous allons installer une
aire de jeu de ce qu'on appelle les
fidèles aujourd'hui ce qu'il ya une
attente de la population pour faire du
sport en extérieur voilà s'en allait
forcément dans un club
la réalisation de pistes cyclables et
l'embellissement de deux ronds points
aux couleurs djo sont au programme
également de la rénovation car le projet
se fera en parallèle d'un autre grand
dossier l'aménagement de la colline
d'elancourt qui accueillera les épreuves
de vtt de paris 2024 ces travaux seront
effectués par soli deo la société de
livraison des ouvrages olympique le
projet de l'aménagement la colline et en
français la conservation titre olympique
pour pouvoir accueillir
dans le futur de nouvelles compétitions
ainsi possible mais le développement
d'un parc sur la colline un parc de
loisirs et un parc sportif
pour pour un usage diversifiée des
changements conséquents pour la clé de
saint pierre que la ville a présenté
samedi 21 mai aux habitants lors de
l'événement mon quartier demain et
quartiers déjà des sites alizés mêlant
battre et à rentrer plus de végétaux
dans le quartier et franchement ça va
bien ça va amener de la végétalisation
et puis ça de la sécurité aussi c'est là
aussi par une trame de vitesse c'est un
beau quartier qui a du potentiel mais je
pense que ya pas mal de choses qui ont
besoin de rénovations et d'être
rafraîchis choco projet là c'est
intéressant de pouvoir après à l'arrêter
ce que allait faire mais rajouter qu aux
espaces verts aménagés je pensais
promenade à coût total du projet 4
millions d'euros subventionnés à 70 %
par la région ile de france le
département des yvelines et saint
quentin en yvelines fin des travaux
prévue au premier semestre 2024
l'office national des forêts organise
actuellement des chantiers nature et ce
en pleine forêt l'idée de sensibiliser
le grand public à la préservation de
l'environnement et miquel et demi
d'euros a pu suivre un atelier de
construction de est sèche c'était à la
madre à deux trappes on va remettre des
branchages on va refaire un lit feuille
morte de façon à éviter l'humidité
maintenant leur permet d'avoir des zones
d'abris objectif aujourd'hui à la mad
ryad de trappes protéger la biodiversité
à travers un chantier nature ce mercredi
18 mai un groupe de saint quentinois
sept inscrits pour participer à un
atelier sur les et sèche organisé par
l'office national des forêts on met la
terre autour on vient mettre des
feuillages et de l'herbe sèche pour
faire un lit pour les hérissons qui vont
se glisser dessous ensuite on va mettre
des branchages et on va remettre par
dessus ces branchages des feuilles
mortes pour leur faire à toi derrière on
va refaire un lit de branchages puis un
lit de feuilles mortes de façon à ce que
les petits passereaux les petits oiseaux
qui viennent y fier dedans puis 7 à
l'abri derrière on aura nous salam en au
triton aux crapauds qui vont venir
passer l'hiver dessous pour constituer
cet environnement les participants ont
besoin de chercher des feuilles du bois
dans la forêt à proximité du site ils
sont équipés de râteaux et de sécateurs
j'ai des branches
coupé de prix prélevés sur des andains
qui sont des tas de bois dans la forêt
et on va les apporter pour constituer un
des éléments d'une est sèche à la fin de
cette session de trois heures les
participants ont fait progresser cet
essai est de mettre environ une petite
avancée dans la préservation des espaces
naturels ça permet de
de remettre la place de l'homme au sein
de
de l'environnement de l'écosystème dans
quel dans lequel on vit les
problématiques environnementales sur le
territoire sont très importantes je suis
très contente et j'espère pouvoir le
reproduire ailleurs non non c'est
vraiment très très bien je trouve ça une
super bonne idée que l'eau nf
effectivement nous propose à la fois la
prendre et puis de participer d'autres
sessions seront programmés dans les
prochaines semaines par lohan f le
samedi 11 juin un nouvel atelier sur les
essais sera organisée dans la forêt de
maurepas sur le site de la mare aux
biches
[Musique]
dernière ligne droite pour secret
défense le week end dernier avait lieu
la dernière grande répétition générale
au château de rambouillet ce spectacle
immersif aura lieu en juin et juillet
prochain les spectateurs seront plongés
en pleine guerre froide et revivront la
rencontre entre eisenhower et le général
de gaulle mathilde francou et céline
charles se sont glissés dans les
coulisses
[Musique]
dernière grande répétition générale pour
le spectacle secret défense produit par
polaris et les monuments nationaux et le
retrace la rencontre entre les
présidents eisenhower et de gaulle en
pleine guerre froide à quelques semaines
de la représentation celle au moment de
régler les derniers détails comme détail
aujourd'hui typiquement il ya une scène
dans le spectacle où deux groupes qui
ont été divisées au début du spectacle
doivent se retrouver et s'ils ne se
retrouvent pas au bon moment et bien ça
décale tout spectacle et c'est compliqué
puisqu'il des admissions public toutes
les dix minutes aujourd'hui on voit
surtout des détails de coiffure de
costumes et des petits détails de mise
en scène qui va aller à mener
l'accessoire d'un figurant un autre pour
que la scène fonctionne bien qui va
ouvrir les portes qui va déclencher les
bandes sont toutes ces derniers calages
de dernière minute qu'on a besoin de
faire forcément après la première qui
dont trois semaines maintenant un
spectacle qui demande beaucoup
d'organisation et de précision puisque
au total ces 600 volontaires qui
deviennent des acteurs des figurants des
choristes ou encore des petites mains en
coulisses je suis un acteur dans la
scène du cabinet je joue thomas gets
junior le secrétaire d'état à la défense
américaine je suis chef d'atelier
avec mes trois coéquipiers donc
marie-christine isabelle et puis renault
sur la chambre des délégations coiffure
décor placement tout est vu et revu pour
que ça soit parfait le jour j après deux
ans de préparation tout le monde est
impatient dans l'ensemble on est quand
même assez près les derniers détails se
met au fur à mesure effectivement
qu'en jouant en jouant mais là on est on
est suffisamment près pour partir plutôt
sereine parce que je suis totalement
confiante déjà dans l'équipe polaris qui
nous accompagnent qui nous donne une
force mais extraordinaire on est sûr ça
va être une belle expérience immersive
pour tous les âges et pour tout les
appétences c'est à dire qu'on ait une
connaissance très précise de l'histoire
où que ce soit pas particulièrement une
période qui nous intéresse c'est
vraiment un spectacle qui s'adresse à
tous et à toutes le spectacle secret
défense se déroulera du 10 juin au 3
juillet au château de rambouillet tous
les vendredis soirs où les samedis et
les dimanches de 9h à 23h les
spectateurs seront immergés en 1959
durant une heure
c'était une première dans les yvelines
le geek up festival ouvrait ses portes
pour la première fois les 21 et 22 mai
aux clayes-sous-bois retour sur cette
convention inédite avec bixente mayence
insisté ban et céline charles
[Musique]
un mélange entre le monde des sorciers
époque médiévale et culture japonaise
c'est la recette proposée par le geek
festival aux clayes-sous-bois pour sa
première édition les fans ont répondu
présent comme ça qu'on fait chez moi je
me suis dit pourquoi pas trouver des
gens qui font du cost est comme moi pour
faire des duos et cetera c'est
l'occasion du coup de m'apporter note qu
est-ce qu en extérieur parce que parfois
on ne sait pas forcément quand c'est pas
dans le cadre d'une convention on voit
souvent des croche-pieds récupérant
l'instant on voit
des personnages qu'on aime bien
les gens
entrent concours de cosplay et échanges
entre passionnés et animations les
festivités se sont déroulées en
extérieur un vrai parti pris des
organisateurs voulaient se différencier
de la région parisienne où on est dans
des grandes salles où tout le monde se
marche quasiment dessus on a quelques
stands du punjab animations qui vont
vendre des frites antijaponaises des
kimonos des chaussettes plein de petits
goodies on a du coup aussi des stands
d'illustration on a en éditeur de mangas
qui ferment gars afro basket mythe ça
parle de deux jeunes adolescents km
annick qui vont parcourir l'afrique donc
gamins dans les mangas donc c'est notre
critique pour devenir des gardiens un
bon gardien c'est des protecteurs des
hommes comme tout grand rendez vous il
faut son lot de stars au big up festival
c'est elle et chris evans et margot
robbie version française je pensais que
la vraie vedette c'était la personne à
l'écran où nous on était un peu
accessoire j'allais dire est en fait pas
du tout pas du tout c'est très
complémentaire et les gens aiment
beaucoup ça ça fait vraiment un retour
critique qui est hyper hyper
enrichissant et constructif pour nous et
puis c'est tellement de gentillesse et
c'est toute la journée que le soir c'est
ont l'impression qu'on est chargé à bloc
pour un mois ou deux la jusqu'au
prochain moment de rencontrer ces masses
est très agréable et même sans compter
les multiples rôles interprétés par les
deux doubles heures l'événement a
accueilli environ 1000 visiteurs lors du
week-end
le festival de cannes se déroule jusqu'à
samedi jusqu'à donc cette date radio
sensations en partenariat avec tv 60,18
vous emmène à la rencontre des
réalisateurs acteurs et producteurs de
notre région mathis godefroy vous emmène
aujourd'hui à la rencontre justement de
benjamins i phrase d'un réalisateur
franciliens qui présente à cannes son
court métrage dans un espace dédié du
palais des festivals le festival de
cannes se sont vus films en compétition
mais aussi des plus petits des courts
métrages ici au palais du festival un
coin est spécialement dédié aux courts
métrages on va à la rencontre de
benjamin il fera il est auteur et
scénariste du film sweet dreams pour la
séance
[Musique]
du coup a commenté le réalisateur du
court-métrage sweet dreams donc on parle
de rêve était à cannes aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que ça représente pour toi
d'être ici au festival c'est une
occasion de fond parce que 4 c
festival eux français en tous cas
surtout curieux de voir ce que ça donne
quoi cannes les marches rouges et
célébrités les costume de pingouin tout
ça ça m'intrigue qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que tu t'es dit avant d'arriver à cannes
qui a été ta vision du festival je me
suis dit
est-ce que ça va être très guindé est-ce
que ça va être
les célébrités
les soirées où tu rentres pas parce que
de toute façon c'est très très high
level est en fait de se jouer c'est
aussi beaucoup de
jean de professionnels
deux jeunes acteurs
émergents qui qui viennent et c'est le
cas de benjamin avec le film sweet
dreams en gros il ya le service
après-vente des rêves
lequel travaille avec beaucoup
d'application sophie 9 qui s'appelle
judith
il ya beaucoup la flemme de travailler à
[Musique]
l'eau que puis-je faire pour vous
messieurs pour le moment où tomas qui
est un client mécontent de ses rêves
parce que ça se termine jamais comme on
veut et sait il appelle il va se heurter
à la flemme de judith et la
communication va venir se passait bien
que des bugs avec votre service là
j'étais en train de rêver que je dînais
avec scarlett johansson au moment où je
l'embrassé je m'aperçois que c'est plus
qu'un litre johann c'est ma mère comment
comment l'idée de ce film devenu toi
c'est un film que j'ai fait pour le
nikon festival cette année le thème
c'était le rêve s'est toujours
intéressée par les périphs technologique
et
j'aime bien faire ce qu'on appelle les
confins ce qu'on appelle c'est pas ça
s'appelle encore comme ça mais des
comédies dystopique benjamin des projets
plein la tête il travaille notamment sur
une série d'animations mais aussi sur
une série historique avant de vous
laisser vous vous apprêtez peut-être à
prendre la route demain mercredi pour le
grand week-end de l'ascension les
prévisions de trafic sont connus bison
futé voit rouge dans le sens des départs
ce mercredi et jeudi en ile-de-france et
dans tout le pays il est conseillé à
chaque fois de quitter ou de traverser
l'ile-de-france avant midi mercredi
avant 7 heures du matin je dis attention
dimanche dans le sens des retours la
couleur vire au noir au niveau national
bison futé vous conseille de revenir ou
de traverser l'ile-de-france avant midi
les bouchons sont prévus jusqu'au moins
19 heures voix 20 voire 20 heures soyez
bien sûr prudents sur les routes voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant le 7-8
culture présentée par célia gars de 100
go belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]